شرطه اسلام اباد وصولها مسيره رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران نخان الى المجمع
القضائي في العاصمه واتهمت الشرطه انصار
خان برشق قواتها بالحجاره واضافتنا
المتظاهرين من انصار خان اعتدوا على
المجمع القضائي واضربوا النار في مركز
شرطه من جانبها قالت حركه انصاف
الباكستانيه ان الشرطه اطلقت قنابل الغاز
بكثافه على انصارها قرب المجمع القضائي في
السامباد واستهدفت سياره عمران خان لمنع
مثوله امام المحكمه
ونقلت وكاله رويترزان قوله ان هناك تهديدا
اكبر لحياته اكثر من ذي قبل واضاف ان
الخصومه السياسيين والمؤسسه العسكريه
يحاولون منعه من العوده الى السلطه كما
وجه خان رساله لمؤيديه من داخل سيارته بعد
خروجهم لاهور حذرهم فيها من وجود مخطط
لاعتقاله في اسلام اباد
اريد ان يعرف الجميع ان هناك مخططا متكامل
الاركان الاعتقالي وهو ما يثبت سوءانيه من
وضع المخطط فانا اصلا كنت سامثل امام
المحكمه ومحاوله اعتقال السابقه من منزلي
في لم تكن لجلب الى المحكمه بل لوضع في
السجن وهذا عمل بمخطط شرير وضعه نواز شريف
في لندن لمنع من المشاركه في الانتخابات
ورغم معرفه بنيه المبيته الاعتقال سامثل
امام المحكمه للتاكيد على ايمان بالقضاء
وبسلطه القانون وايضا لكشف وفضح مخطط
المجرمين الذين يتحكمون في البلد ومن
وضعهم في هذا الموقع والذين يريدون تحكيم
قانون الغاب